I'm going to show you something which is
trivially simple
well we think about all the other
numbers that you've known about square
roots are not hard to work out until
you're in the complex world and they've
been really hard to work out at least
with the tools we've got at the moment
okay so let's just consider consider if
I have a complex number is n and by
definition a complex number has two
components namely X the real part and I
Y the imaginary part I've got these two
pieces okay if I've got this complex
number then my question is what is the
square root of this number right
what is the number I know how to do
multiplication of complex numbers we
talked about that before it's just I
multiply two binomials to fine what
would the square root of this never be
okay now let's just give this number a
name okay I'm going to call it as is its
traditional just like Z is traditional
for complex numbers I'm going to use a
number that a letter looks like a W but
it's not it's actually Omega
it's a lowercase Omega you're probably
more familiar with the upper case Omega
because I think it's the letter they use
for ohms I think right this is a
lowercase honestly if you write it as a
double you know one will win but the
difference between 2w because now I
write my w's and this is an Omega can
you see the difference now so it's kind
of yeah that's right that's right so say
these your absolute values and easier
anyway okay so I don't know what the
square root of Z is okay but I'm just
gonna give it an it because that's what
algebra is do they're like well if I
don't know something I'll give it a
label then I'll see what I can come up
with now can you see from this line by
definition if Omega is the square root
of Z right then Omega squared should be
equal to Z by definition
do you agree with them okay now I'm just
gonna adjust this ever so slightly I'm
going to write this amazing screen I'm
going to put him on the left hand side
and make this all on one side something
like this maybe it's going to take away
Z is equal to zero can you see what I
did was I subtracted that from both
sides and then I put everything on the
left now you have to put a big box
around this you might think you think
what I'm said anything profound have I
but I have I said something enormously
profound which I kind of you might not
realize how how deep and significant
this is because I scared it over very
quickly yesterday right what is this
thing right
Zed is some constant okay I don't know
what it is but it's a constant of some
kind okay but maker is a number and I
don't know what it is okay it's a
variable as it were now therefore what
I've just written is a polynomial in
omega right we're used to writing like
quadratics in X or quadratics in Y or
cubic cenotes or qubits in life this is
a polynomial it's a quadratic in omega
and the reason why I point this out is
because I told you at ease last lesson
this thing called the fundamental
theorem of algebra okay
now the fundamental theorem of average
states that if you have a polynomial a
be polynomial that has complex
coefficients what's the coefficient of
Omega square what what's the coefficient
of the constant what's just said which
is a complex number this is a polynomial
with complex coefficients therefore I
know that the solutions to this
polynomial are also complex numbers do
you see that do you understand the
implication if this is a polynomial and
it's got complex coefficients the
fundament of the United States it must
have a complex solution complex roots
okay therefore I know I can write Omega
as a complex number I know
used X and I right so first I could say
a plus IB that's another common
designation for a complex number again
there's a real part a and there's an
imaginary part
B ok so that was really important I
can't move any further unless I know
that the square root of a complex number
must also itself be a complex number
right do you see how important that is
because for instance the square root of
a rational number is not a rational
number right you don't necessarily stay
in that set of numbers but when you
should hit the complex numbers like I
was saying it's the end of the line you
have all of the numbers that you can
come up algebraically with okay